[Música]
e
qué tal bienvenidos a canadá en las
américas café o el castor cibernética
como también lo conocemos los saluda
paloma martínez desde nuestros estudios
en la ciudad de montreal aquí en el
estudio justamente tengo varias personas
a mi lado varios que ustedes conocen y
uno que ustedes no conocen leonor a
chapman
leonardo gimeno paulo gomes barrio y un
invitado especial juan vázquez
bienvenido
ya os vamos a decir quién es juan
vázquez y por qué está aquí con nosotros
hoy los invitamos a que nos sigan por
www.uned.es saludamos a aquellos que
están por facebook live por youtube live
o por cualquier otro medio que nos estén
siguiendo
gracias por su sintonía también os
recordamos que viene el programa tenemos
temas muy interesantes como viajar al
espacio
rebeliones contra la extinción
leonardo hizo un poco de ruido por lo
queremos igual
molestando con sus celulares hablaremos
también de mejores medicamentos y de la
crisis en ecuador
pero antes como les decía tenemos un
invitado especial se trata de juan bas
que es juan vásquez es candidato del
partido verde en la circunscripción para
pino de montreal así que muchas gracias
por estar aquí con nosotros bienvenidos
gracias por la invitación y gustos para
quien su programa les explicamos que
juan es homeópata naturópata profesional
de aquí de la ciudad de milán
actualmente va muy bien con su
personalidad es miembro del equipo de
desarrollo sostenible de su banco del
banco nacional de canadá donde trabaja y
ha participado en las últimas cinco
conferencias de naciones unidas sobre
cambio climático y en la conferencia río
+20 sobre desarrollo sostenible entonces
es un tema recurrente en su vida
profesional y en su vida personal
también el estar del lado de el cambio
climático de la de la lucha contra el
cambio climático de la protección del
medio ambiente tienes lo que es en el
costado verde entonces del partido
del lado verde del corazón de la linda y
bueno juan también fue el candidato para
el partido verde de quebec en las
campañas en la campaña provincial en
2018 y qué va a pasar si ganas un poco
con el banco nacional de canadá pues me
tendrá que ir a ottawa y olvidar
un pequeño reto en el distrito de justin
[Música]
le dijo adiós y dijo no momento todo lo
mentiroso lo estoy lo es todo esto que
es el candidato de papi no por el con
dijo papi
entonces juan es su contrincante es el
primer ministro de canadá que está
saliendo y claro y que se está
presentando como candidato en ese en esa
circunscripción la circunscripción de
papi no aquí en la ciudad de montreal
posible deporte lo importante es
participar pero que todo es posible a en
una elección no sabemos que no va a
perdonar la gente como fue pasar de ser
parte de una campaña de un candidato
provincial al federal cuál es la
diferencia pues las diferencias son
ciertas políticas evidentemente pues el
federal es como un poco pues todo canadá
son políticas más nacionales y la
diferencia en sí no es tanta porque
detrás de la política de todos los
partidos verdes en el mundo hay
principios
de base que sostienen justamente los
valores de todas las campañas políticas
que tiene que ver por ejemplo el
desarrollo sostenible
el apoyo a los pueblos indígenas el
derecho a la tierra a vivir y existir
con todos los seres los seres vivientes
entonces hay valores que existen en
todos los partidos ya sea en europa en
latinoamérica o aquí en norteamérica
entonces la base es la misma pero
después de cómo se va a dividir o cómo
se va desplegando las políticas
dependiendo del territorio como como la
naturaleza la naturales es igual pero se
desarrolla dice
se manifiesta diferente
[Aplausos]
esto mismo ti verde también la niña
juan cuéntanos cómo va la campaña
electoral para el partido verde en
general para la jefa del partido verde
elisabeth may que ayer estuvo en el
debate en lengua francesa se defendió se
defendió no es su lengua materna pero se
defendió bien en este debate entonces
cómo va la campaña para el partido verde
de canadá pues la verdad si una aventura
muy muy interesante para el partido
verde somos un partido emergente y pues
lo vemos como otra vez yo lo relaciono
todas con naturaleza como una bola
porque estamos creciendo estamos
haciendo un llamado
están haciendo un llamado a los
ciudadanos para que podamos tomar más
conciencia con lo que está sucediendo
con respecto al cambio climático y una
economía que sea más está relacionada
con el medio ambiente pero en general
estamos bien sabemos que no vamos a ser
el partido que vamos a tener mayoría
pero cree creemos y tenemos la confianza
de que nosotros venimos a llenar a
llevar a todos los otros políticos a un
liderazgo con sentido con respecto a
todo lo que es de urgencia climática y
la transformación de nuestra economía
nuestra sociedad canadiense sí igual en
el primer en el primer debate que fue el
lunes pasado el es el inglés justin todo
en un momento dado se dio vuelta miró a
la jefa de tu partido le dije le dijo
podríamos trabajar juntos o sea ese es
el objetivo yo creo que el partido verde
no busca
como la gran ola verde que todo cambio
busca el poder o no obviamente preguntar
no el poder como el poder como tal eso
de lo que escuchamos de la candidata a
ser también en el otro que ya es
colaboradora es con esto que la ola
verde no sea solamente una cuestión de
ser bien en las elecciones y después no
solamente una foto contigo realmente de
poder en sí pero realmente de como ya lo
dice mucho estamos en una situación de
tanta urgencia que necesitamos la
colaboración de cada partido pero yo
creo que si el partido verde llegará al
poder
tal vez las políticas serían más
rápidamente entonces la vida del poder
es el poder no hay que negarlo pero
hasta el deseo está el ideal de lo que
queremos ser y también está la realidad
pero que somos entonces tratar de
armonizar esas dos realidades que es
nuestras ganas de querer ganar nuestras
ganas de llevar nuestras políticas
adelante pero también sabiendo
donde estamos con los pies en la tierra
evidentemente ahora lo estábamos
evocando es un momento te presentas en
la circunscripción de yuste en trudeau
que es bastante popular en su
circunscripción como tal aquí en
montreal es una circunscripción muy
diversa y la gente lo quiere mucho en
este en este barrio por qué escogiste
esa circunscripción y no otra que a lo
mejor hubiera sido más fácil para ti
estás obligado a vivir ahí para ser
candidato
pero está bueno yo pedí lanzarme en eso
la realidad es que yo tengo 20 años
viendo en canadá 20 años viendo en vilar
y es mi barrio es mi sector es mi lugar
donde crecí aquí en canadá y para mí
pues es una forma de regresar a ese
lugar ese espacio que me vio crecer aquí
en canadá regresar un poco eso como
servicio
a este sector y pues por qué no tener un
desafío así es poder entonces
estar contra el primer mito para mí es
una oportunidad de mejorar me y hacer
las cosas aún mejor y por qué no decir
yo tengo podemos hacer todavía mejor
a través del ejemplo y creo que para mí
ese es un desafío que yo quería tomar y
yo sé que la mejor el camino para llegar
a ganarla yo quién puede ser más largo
al fort no puede ser este esta elección
porque no sabes pero puedes analizar la
posible entonces la vida te va a ofrecer
caminos alternativos dijiste que estás
hace 20 años acá en canadá que si es que
hacías antes era niño
con mi mamá y mi hermana venimos todos
aquí de donde son de méxico méxico pero
acá de ciudad de méxico pero que es en
monterrey y bueno pues venir aquí nos
abrieron puertas y oportunidades no
además económicas sino también de
bienestar de salud de crecimiento
personal entonces es lo bonito de este
país que nos da más el nivel económico
es el nivel del bienestar y creo que
para mí también es algo que me enfoco
mucho en la política es el bienestar de
las personas porque la economía
simplemente es una parte muy importante
pero todo lo demás es un todo pues yo lo
hago así como algo más dinámico más
completo si me parecía de más juego me
parece además interesante que es ver que
sos una persona originaria de américa
latina que estás implicado en la
política es que hay otros otros y otras
personas de origen latinoamericano que
se están implicando en la política aquí
en quebec sí de hecho tengo un debate el
domingo pasado en la radio en magill
donde estuvimos cuatro candidatos
tres mujeres tres de chile y original de
chile cada vez en diferentes partidos
del blog
del nuevo partido democrático
exactamente yo es que había alguien del
partido conservador no respondieron no
respondió en el conservador y el partido
popular no respondieron a la invitación
nosotros estuvimos buscando y no
encontramos candidatos de origen
latinoamericano aunque pudieran hablar
español ni del ni del partido
conservador ni del partido popular pero
si alguien nos está escuchando y hay
algún candidato por ahí que quiera venir
estamos en búsqueda porque vamos a tener
a pablo ya entre nuestro
martínez cerrada es justamente ese
candidata en la circunscripción de hoy
la game on net
y paulina ya la del nuevo partido
democrático en la zona de montreal norte
va a venir la semana próxima aquí al
programa entonces bueno estamos en
búsqueda de otros candidatos de los
otros hablando en español
[Risas]
hola amigos cómo fue que te interesaste
en el tema del medio ambiente de dónde
viene esto de la familia o de quién
estudió geografía y yo desde niño
siempre me gustó mucho la naturaleza me
acuerdo ver en los canales donde pasaban
los animales sin papá siempre me tenían
cíclope díaz de animales y para mí fue
siempre como pues algo el tiempo para me
inculcó mucho esa conciencia de llamar a
la tierra de respetar a la tierra a
respetar a la humanidad entonces de niño
crecí con esa conciencia con ese llamado
de la sensibilidad particular por el
medio ambiente exactamente y de niño
también en la escuela en la primaria en
méxico me lancé como para presidente de
mi primaria
desde chiquito entonces la política la
traes en la política de práctica no lo
que quieres es que sea algo práctico y
rentable invitar a la gente a que se una
porque realmente también esperamos mucho
pero también el cambio es tan importante
que necesitamos ahora que yo haga un
llamado a la sociedad y a todos los
acompañarme en este movimiento porque es
un movimiento de regeneración de
transformación que va que es tan
importante que a veces no hemos podido
dimensionar ese cambio que es y por eso
decimos tanto la agencia climática y
para mí es una invitación para que todos
hagamos cambio desde dentro entonces
pues si hacer la política de forma
diferente yo te pediría juan porque hay
gente que nos está escuchando como dice
siempre pablo si tuvieras que dar dos
consejos importantes los más importantes
para vos para preservar o no perjudicar
el medio ambiente a gente común y
corriente como nosotros que le dirías
cuál es pues el primero es de que no hay
que salvar al medio ambiente no hay que
cuidar meramente
sino que este es un cambio de conciencia
que tenemos que tomar que nosotros somos
los glaciares nosotros somos los bosques
nosotros somos el agua somos el mar
somos hijos de la madre natural se hizo
viene de nuestras raíces autóctonas
indígenas y son ellos los que nos han
enseñado a entender esta conciencia tan
profunda de lo que yo hago lo estoy
haciendo a mí mismo lo que yo haga el
planeta lo estoy haciendo la sociedad
entonces es entender y amar a la madre
tierra para mí empieza a través del
corazón primero y después entendiendo
que cualquier cosa que hagamos de forma
práctica pueden tener un impacto aunque
sea individual pero después colectivo lo
veo por ejemplo el movimiento del lo que
se dice es cero desechos y hago de
training in francés en el cual empezaron
principalmente mujeres y ahora a través
de ellas a dando el ejemplo y es un
movimiento mundial entonces hay
movimientos que van creciendo a través
de el cambio personal y para mí es eso
pues una parte muy importante de este
cambio entonces cualquier pequeño
esto es es importante cuenta claro y
hablando de gestos justamente lo que yo
aplico es en mi pequeña contribución al
medio ambiente
así que lo hago constantemente cuando
uno se cepilla los dientes por ejemplo
cerrar la llave mientras está cepillando
área y no dejar correr el agua
a otro el otro pequeño aspecto es
siempre apagar las luces que no
necesitas en casa donde me llamó la
atención que aquí en la de canadá y no
hay tanta luz y es bueno porque a veces
tanta luz tanto los reflectores estamos
con un ambiente más tranquilo hace cinco
o seis años en guagua que es una de las
presas hidroeléctricas aquí cerquita de
montreal
señora decía con dos bombillas en una
casa se generan 30 segundos de vuelta de
unos entonces pensando en eso es como es
porque estoy apagando o dejando de hacer
funcionar esos 30 segundos
ahora cuando se tiene chicos hay que
estar siempre detrás
veinte años después de comer los platos
mojo lavabo y después en juego no dejo
el agua por ciento hay mucha gente que
deja la hogar viendo sus pequeños gestos
quizás no ahora pero en un futuro pueden
degradar y que están al alcance nuestro
no se necesita un gran esfuerzo
aquí hay mensajes mensajes miriam
alarcón hola desde tucumán argentina hoy
con 40 grados de temperatura está viendo
el programa con florencia y fabricio mis
hijos temas muy interesantes
betancourt dice saludos al equipo de
profesional del 6 desde el estado de
oxaca mágica
oaxaca méxico muy buena transmisión
pablo dice que está mirando y poniendo
el sonido fuerte
[Risas]
en él se encontrará rincón buenas tardes
saludos desde el carmen norte de
santander colombia barranquilla debe
estar de paseo
buenas tardes luz baldera dice que les
comparto la mala noticia en vitoria
conquista el espacio o fue deseo el
cosmonauta ruso alexei leónov fue el
primero que caminó en el espacio en 1965
al año siguiente vino a nuestra ciudad
de san antonio donde fue nombrado
ciudadano ilustre por esa hazaña
falleció en el de donde es bandera
antonio texas
que no se escucha desde hace mucho pues
tenemos a gustavo luques saludos de la
ciudad de melo departamento sólo el
árbol uruguay feliz día de acción de
gracias el próximo lunes
mercedes alaya dice hola saludos desde
chile mercedes dice cuándo y qué año
disculpen y de le pregunta a luis sobre
el padecimiento del ebro y miran alarcón
dice aquí en américa latina como en el
resto del mundo debido a la desigualdad
los programas el cambio climático afecta
más a los pobres qué bueno que vean el
tema de las políticas públicas de
materia de manera integral dice no juega
la economía estar por encima de todo
tenemos hasta ahora el ejército
prácticamente a toda médica de pulgada
de tus labios
bebiendo tus palabras bueno juan
muchísimas gracias por haber pasado por
nuestros estudiantes puedes quedar aquí
con nosotros si así lo deseas y no
tienes que ir a continuar la campaña por
ahí por las calles de montreal pero
gracias por haber pasado les recordamos
que juan es candidato del partido verde
de canadá en la circunscripción de papi
no aquí en la ciudad de montreal así que
muchas gracias por haber pasado por acá
por nuestros estudios sobre las por
invitación y si tengo que trabajar lo
entendemos pero gracias a la elección
que continúa bien la campaña y la semana
que te queda
y nosotros vamos a seguir vamos a poner
el videito de la aplicación porque es un
vídeo de vídeo vídeo
porque es corto
entonces el vídeo de la aplicación
porque la gente leonardo puede bajar la
aplicación en su teléfono celular
y exactamente y ponerla en su teléfono y
consultar todos nuestros programas
nuestras públicas de meditación a esa
fotografía la primera que aparece pues
se ve el cacho de territorio que es
canadá bueno ustedes pueden en realidad
nuestro sitio internet pueden encontrar
en la columna derecha en la parte de
abajo en este momento luego veremos
hacia arriba
el pequeño banner publicitario la imagen
donde hacen clic y pueden ir al lugar
donde están especificadas las dos
tiendas en donde uno puede ir a bajar la
aplicación son las dos tiendas más
conocidas a postor y google store
entonces o google play the block cambian
cada dos minutos el nombre así que lo
interesante es que ustedes vayan ahí y
hagan clic en el link para ir a bajar la
aplicación la aplicación es fantástica
tienen la posibilidad de ver este mismo
programa en vivo y en directo sin ningún
tipo de problemas todos los vídeos que
nosotros producimos todos los reportajes
que radican en está nacional en español
produce si bajan la versión en español
la pueden viajar bajar
en las otras lenguas para la gente que
vive en canadá y que habla aparte del
español inglés o francés o ambos nuestra
aplicación tiene la posibilidad arriba a
la derecha de ir a ver a consultar
directamente los artículos más
interesantes de esas dos lenguas así que
los invito a que vayan a nuestro sitio
en temas y que hagan lo propio van a
hacer el clic para bajar la aplicación
en sus teléfonos y they precipiten se
precipiten si queremos en mucha gente
nos siga por ahí también muchas gracias
y bueno el principio del programa les
dije como sabemos en ecuador ecuador
está en crisis los indígenas
ecuatorianos que ya han hecho caer
varios presidentes como lo sabemos están
siguiendo su lucha por el aumento contra
el aumento de los precios de los
combustibles que además implica el
aumento de los productos de la canasta
básica porque claro para que uno pudiera
comprar algo tienen que llegar entrar en
transporte y es combustible también
entonces están en pie de lucha
los ecuatorianos particularmente los
grupos indígenas y nuestro fiel oyente y
seguidor manfred echeverría que además
también es un colega porque trabaja en
medios
en medios de comunicación allá en
ecuador nos envió unas imágenes del
ecuador de las manifestaciones que están
teniendo lugar y de hecho también mandó
un el sonido de su vídeo no sé dónde nos
explica lo que lo que estamos viendo en
este momento estamos viendo otras
imágenes del ecuador de las
manifestaciones como tal hubo dos
muertos hasta el momento es en el
entierro de una persona perdón hay cinco
muertos hay cerca de mil detenidos hay
cerca de más de 600 heridos pero son
cinco muertos
estaban evolucionando muy rápidamente
les oí lo que está pasando en el ecuador
entonces por eso le pedimos a man pero
como les pedimos a todos ustedes cuando
hay eventos específicos de sus lugares
de origen que no se envíen vídeos que
nos envíen imágenes de estas fotografías
están muy buenas si esas son muy buenas
pero podemos también ver el vídeo de
nuestro colega manfred nuestro oyente
seguidor muy fiel oyente y seguidor
manfred echeverría
nos tiene ahí vamos a verlas ahora mismo
en el nos estamos viendo también él lo
hizo al vídeo él lo filmó el west lo
mandó de otro lado no el mismo lo filma
ja eso sí tiene el sonido podemos tal
vez escuchar su voz en la que nos
explica lo que lo que está sucediendo el
cuando no más que pudimos captar antes
los votos las diez y media desde ahí se
encuentran las diferentes organizaciones
y líderes en asamblea permanente tomando
decisiones y medidas a tomar en esta
paralización que hoy cumple su séptimo
día alrededor de unas 60 personas
duermen en el interior a pesar de estar
en un estado de excepción y haber un
toque de queda que nadie puede transitar
por los edificios públicos de 20 horas a
5 horas de la mañana la calle de parque
de luces negras por la quema de
neumáticos los víveres van escaseando y
no se avisora ninguna deuda el gobierno
por su parte no da el brazo a torcer y
los indígenas de unas fuerzas vivas de
igual manera hasta que no se derogue el
decreto 833 que principalmente subieron
los combustibles y por ende la canasta
familiar
entonces estábamos escuchando la voz de
manfred echeverría y nos contaba que
bueno que se espera que la gente está
esperando a la gente la ciudadanía es
esperando que se retomen la calma que
pero que bueno las cosas están
evolucionando y lo que nos decía es que
ese es el palacio de gobernación de
chimborazo donde están reunidas las
principales organizaciones y líderes de
la asamblea permanente tomando las
decisiones con respecto a lo que va a
pasar digamos en los próximos días y de
hecho están ahí claro en contra de la
del toque de queda y en contra de todas
las limitaciones que les está dando las
autoridades porque les dicen que no se
reúnan ahí pero ellos están igual ahí
reunidos
si ya hay que decir que ecuador tiene 17
millones de habitantes los cuales un 25
por ciento es población indígena y hay
que decir también para tal vez entender
lo que está pasando un 65 por ciento de
los pobres en ecuador que son indígenas
son indígenas se habla de que un 50 por
ciento de los niños menores de 4 años
sufren de desnutrición
permanente entonces yo creo que si
ponemos en contexto se entiende mejor
entonces porque están manifestando como
decía paloma el aumento del combustible
son los indígenas son sobre todo
productores agrícolas pequeños
productores agrícolas y este aumento del
combustible que lo que dicen es que
aumentó en un 123 por ciento afecta no
sólo el transporte personal de la gente
porque suben los boletos del transporte
sino comprar esa nafta o gasolina donde
ellos transportan sus sus comidas o sus
productos para vender en los mercados
entonces se les está encareciendo todo
eso temen que haya inflación a causa de
todo lo que está sucediendo entonces y
es eso lo que hace que yo entiendo que
han salido pues todos a manifestar ahí
su descontento y aparte de eso se dice
también que las aldeas por ejemplo de
poblaciones indígenas muchas de ellas no
tienen agua potable y carecen de
electricidad entonces hay hay un
contexto ahí
y sufrimiento y de pobreza a veces
extraño está desesperada se nota que
está desesperada y entonces eso es de
eso se trata en estas tres estaciones de
expresar esta desesperación y digamos un
poco de impaciencia ahora león mono ya
van cinco siglos
el racismo
también siempre ha sido las poblaciones
olvidadas o sea nadie lo tiene en cuenta
eso sucede aquí en canadá y sucede en
muchos lugares y a eso hay que agregarle
además digo la presencia de empresas
internacionales empresas globales
multinacionales en los territorios de
hecho a leonor esta semana estuviste
conversando con una persona de la
universidad de ottawa si el que además
representa un organismo si representa el
organismo
se llama alerta minera canadá ella es
kirsten francesconi coordinadora de este
organismo mining watch en américa latina
para poner un poquito solamente en
contexto hay que decir que este plan del
presidente moreno en ecuador significa
exigencias del fondo monetario
internacional es lo que normalmente se
llama ajustes estructurales que ya se
conoce un poco lo que son el impacto en
las poblaciones por ejemplo una de las
exigencias es que se implementó es que
el govern el gob el gobierno ahora
destina una contribución especial a las
empresas que ganen o que con ingresos de
más de 10 millones de dólares anuales
para un paño claro entonces bajan un
xala los salarios de los contractuales
en un 20 por ciento que le están
cobrando un día de trabajo a todos los
empleados del ecuador se lo guarda el
gobierno necesitan stanton están
empobreciendo a la población y a eso se
le agrega
el aumento del precio posible
es todo un paquete de exigencias de
ajustes económicos del fondo monetario
internacional del banco mundial y esto
lo que dice en la entrevista a kirsten
franke stoner ella lo que dice es que
estas medidas de austeridad buscan abrir
a ecuador a la inversión extranjera que
es la exigencia del fondo monetario
internacional del banco interamericano y
otros prestamistas internacionales
también lo que ella dice es que ahí está
el ángulo de esta entrevista que las
empresas mineras canadienses son también
responsables de lo que está sucediendo
en ecuador ella se refiere que
actualmente hay 12 mineras canadienses
con más de 40 proyectos mineros en
ecuador en todo el país y lo que están
haciendo por ejemplo con estas medidas
es que lo que ella decía están
aprovechando las mineras canadienses de
la situación actual de esta crisis para
promover sus proyectos
están como convenciendo a sus
accionistas de que hay que invertir más
porque hay una ley en ecuador que
prohíbe hasta cierto punto un porcentaje
de inversiones mineras entonces están
revirtiendo todo eso no entonces hay
sentido implicaría diga más abril es
como ella dice a abrir el ecuador
a las inversiones extranjeras y lo que
esto está afectando particularmente a
las poblaciones indígenas es que estas
mineras están entrando a sus tierras y
entonces se perjudica ya sabemos las
cosas buenas cuando es una una
explotación minera indiscriminada pues
la tierra empieza a sufrir se deja de
producir los productos que se llama
realmente aparte que independent que es
lo que están buscando qué es lo que
encuentran los procesos normalmente para
limpiar minerales se usa cianuro esos
residuos se tiran los ríos el contaminan
ríos contaminan bosques o sea si hubiera
estado con nosotros todavía
el partido verde liberado en ataque
hay que señalar también que el ecuador
se acaba de retirar no hace mucho de la
opep y se acaba de retirar de la opep
porque encuentra que el esquema de lo de
la opep lo limita y quieren explotar más
petróleo pero los críticos los que
piensan y lo que dicen es que el
petróleo que quieren ir a buscar se
encuentra en la amazonía
así que ya sabemos manos negras se
acuerdan de esa de esa campaña de
denuncia de la petrolera shell creo que
fue la que contaminó un área increíble
en el amazonas y bueno pues piensan
regresar a las zonas a seguir explotando
ese petróleo y quienes viven en el
amazonas las primeras las primeras
naciones que son los que están en la
calle de hoy exactamente entonces bueno
estamos siguiendo aquí en radio canadá
internacional el tema del ecuador si
tienen más imágenes algunos de ustedes
que nos están escuchando por allá o si
hay gente aquí en canadá
quiera también comentar al respecto
estamos abiertos para que vengan a
comentar ya ya vernos como lo están
viendo ustedes también así que gracias
leonor ese reportaje lo encuentran en
nuestro sitio internet www.sprint.com o
les dije al principio si hay mensajes si
trae un mensaje juan castillo dice hola
envía un abrazo enorme a mi gran amigo
pablo gómez barrios y a todos los que
hacen el casto mensajero juan que esté
jairo castillo
[Risas]
[Música]
antiguo en la onda corta y ahora nos
sigue por internet dice que por
problemas con su pc no tiene audio pero
nos puede ver en vivo
del estado a montreal y se les envió un
saludo amistad cariño y fraternidad
esperando algún día dios mediante poder
conocerlos a todos
jairo castillo jairo juan castillo
mandar este mensaje después tenemos
otros mensajes dice mercedes aranda o la
salud de chile
[Música]
esta saludo a pablo gómez cuantos años
seguíamos en la familia y se sigue
siguiendo el castor mensajero desde san
antonio chile en mercedes araya césar
rodríguez charlize y saludos de bogotá a
los escucha videntes ya no somos más
sabedores ahora somos vídeos
gracias gracias por estar siempre ahí
vuestra voluntad y se podrían comentar
sobre el día de acción de gracias en
canadá bueno lo interesante es que no es
el mismo que en eeuu la masacre a los
pavos la más conocida más conocida como
la masacre de los pavos la acción de
gracia estuviera de inglaterra me
pareció la inglaterra un poco más
antigua escocia donde los ricos pues se
daban un gran festín ese día y las obras
iban para los empleados de lo que es el
fin de la cosecha se ha cosechado todo
entonces se festeja de alguna forma
bueno porque hay que recordar que son
se festeja es feriado en realidad
entonces es bueno familia y pavo al
horno ese pasa en su avanzado pero bueno
es una cuestión
mercedes alaya y saludos a pablo aún
recuerdo que esto mensajero cada domingo
en familia un abrazo fraternal para todo
el equipo del 6
homero mendizábal dice gracias por la
información de ecuador y por toda la
información tan imparcial saludos desde
praga ya pronto les mandaré un vídeo
cortísimo sobre algún evento o algo de
aquí por favor homero con fraga que
parece que es una ciudad hermosísima
entonces queremos conocer último mensaje
miriam alarcón dice fm y con esas
medidas genera más desigualdad y pobreza
en nuestra región y no sólo ecuador
argentina y tantos otros países que
están sufriendo por el embate de estas
medidas del fm y cuando vos hablaba de
la subida del precio de los combustibles
del petróleo tal no implica solamente
eso sea el transporte de los alimentos
es el petróleo el transporte de los
alimentos solo tanto con las comidas
salvo
el sueldo de las personas
obviamente y con la cantidad de
ocupación
la desigualdad es brutal y eso es lo que
decía también manfred que bueno con el
aumento del precio de la gasolina y del
petróleo de todos los combustibles pues
aumenta el precio de los productos de la
canasta básica entonces la gente no
puede comprar para comer así que el
nuevo público además o sea las familias
que son numerosas por ejemplo que tienen
que agarrar un bus le cuesta muchísimo
más caro moverse de un lugar así que de
nuevo muchas gracias a manfred por
habernos enviado estas imágenes de
chimborazo allá en el ecuador y como ya
no nos queda mucho tiempo tenemos que ir
rápido hablando de los temas saludemos a
la gente
saludamos a la gente que está del otro
lado de la cabina que nos ayude en todo
este proceso en este proyecto precioso
programa que pone una camarita para
mostrar lo que tenemos a pie si la piel
libre ya marcando que dejan que nos
ayudan cada semana así que muchas
gracias máximo q
y entonces se pone por bien generamos
empleos
[Risas]
leonardo esta semana más cables de
viajes espaciales por favor si hay
turismo espacial en realidad es el
primer guiño al turismo espacial esta es
una empresa privada bueno que en
realidad lo interesante del tema es que
hay cuatro space ex es el de los más y
está de virgin org
orbyt son empresas que empiezan a
generar
elementos para soñar con la carrera
hacia el espacio
en este caso virgin orbit con su una
subsidiaria digamos de virgin galactic
porque es
de brands con un señor muy rico en
inglés el tipo había dicho hace un par
de años que quería ser la primera
empresa para llevar turismo
más bien al espacio en realidad y
evidentemente es una
una cosa bastante utópica pero no tanto
como va creciendo la tecnología hoy en
día
este hombre ha hecho generar una
alternativa que se las cuento en la
crónica que es lanzamiento de satélites
procede de un avión desde el avión es
que vemos ahí el orbit y van a tienen
una especie de misil entre comillas de
abajo que en realidad es un cohete en la
misión y eso allá adentro ahí adentro
mandan los satélites los pequeños
atentos y eso la gran revolución es que
hoy en día para mandar un satélite
no se meteorológico el espacio se gastan
millones y millones de dólares en
plataformas cosas
esto sería muchísimo más barato entonces
sería muchísimo más fácil y a partir de
esto la posibilidad de seguir creciendo
y que en algún momento un viaje similar
provoque la salida de una nave para ir
hasta esos son todos los proyectos se
los cuento en detalle en la crónica
tecnológica y decidí que no sé si se
recuerdan
viendo esta imagen me lo hace pensar que
al principio
los transbordadores espaciales los
primeros transbordadores pensaban
lanzarlos a través de con la ayuda de un
boeing de un avión que era el que iba a
servir de propulsor pero no fue
suficientemente fuerte después lo
utilizaron pues para moverlos de un
lugar a otro de cabo cañaveral
a la otra la otra plataforma de
lanzamiento en california pero no
funcionó lo de enviarlos exactamente lo
que decía no no todavía no estamos
hablando pasajeros
estamos hablando de lo que empieza
dentro de un mes nada más es utilizar
este sistema para lanzar satélites que
después podría transformarse en lo que
aquí hay muchos subsidios de empresas
privadas por ejemplo no sé si coca-cola
está poniendo pero las alas esas rojas
con blanco
la marca de este hombre si tienen no le
den no necesite de cocacola visión bueno
vamos ahora el tema de pablo pablo tú
nos hablas del movimiento extinción
rebelión que se podría traducir como
rebelión contra la extinción es que
damos a los demás modelos ecológicos que
hicieron una entrada triunfal a varias
ciudades del mundo
es relativamente nuevo como movimiento
en 2018 se creó en inglaterra
[Música]
hasta el momento hay estados unidos
italia alemania australia nueva zelanda
francia bélgica suiza canadá quebec
donde hay
con grupos grupos de extensión rebelión
rebelión y hicieron una entrada
espectacular este martes 8 de octubre
aquí en montreal y golpearon donde más
duele porque me duele porque se fueron y
escalaron y subieron a la estructura del
puente ya cartilla de liga en la mañana
al alba que es cuando hay más tráfico
cuando toda la gente que vive en las
afueras de mostrar en la ribera sur que
vienen hacia montreal para trabajar
pregunta amigo pierre que está allá y me
mira mal y cuando alguien ese entonces
ellos extensión reunión yo lo que
hicieron fue que hicieron esta entrada
triunfal entre paréntesis
entre comillas diría y en la mañana y
empecé empezó a hablar del grupo que
ellos su objetivo es de influenciar a
los gobiernos del mundo y las políticas
medioambientales globales mediante la
resistencia no violenta y eso tengo la
importancia también que sea un violento
como grupo y lo que quieren es minimizar
el calentamiento global entonces ellos
no violenta es la intención la violencia
que había en las calles el lunes pero no
eran ellos bueno de alguna forma
generaban pero ellos no son violentos en
su intervención y bueno eso fue en la
mañana y en la tarde volvieron a repetir
en la calle rdlv que el bulevar que pasa
aquí en frente a esta casa allá en el
oeste entonces y se acostaron en el piso
en la calle en el bulevar e
interrumpieron evidentemente el tráfico
entonces pues
este nuevo muy bien hablé con el
director del servicio de prensa del
movimiento aquí en quebec y él explica
bueno con más detalles habla español
la entrevista es en español y pues no
nos explica que cuál es cuál es el
objetivo que es lo que persigue y por
qué lo están haciendo y de hecho
lanzaron esta campaña el primer el 7 de
octubre en todos esos países que
mencionaste varios diferentes maneras de
intervenir a la cola desobedecieron
desobediencia civil sin violencia no es
de extrañar en el debate de ayer
justamente el segundo y el último debate
electoral donde estuvieron los seis
líderes de los partidos federales en
canadá el tema más importante y
realmente crucial fue el medio ambiente
y con eso se inició también un poco el
debate entonces es urgente yo creo que
bueno los políticos se están dando
cuenta y la gente está presionando
pero paloma si yo yo les presentó esta
semana una entrevista con una científica
de origen uruguayo estudió en la
universidad de la república del uruguay
y ahora hizo su doctorado en universidad
mcgill y trabaja en el hospital para
niños ella es parte de hecho dirige un
grupo internacional de investigación que
llegaron que lograron crear un método
para acelerar el proceso de producción
de medicamentos y para prever los
efectos negativos que los medicamentos
pueden tener en la salud antes de que
vayan al mercado el ensayo clínico y al
ya la práctica a la puesta digamos en
marcha del proceso de dar dárselos a los
a los enfermos entonces lo que explica
esta mujer que se llama graciela piñeiro
es que lograron clasificar un gran
número de medicamentos y al
clasificarlos pudieron meter en la
computadora toda la información y los
resultados que ya habían dado en otros
en otros casos de ensayos clínicos y
prever los efectos no deseados
y deseados de los medicamentos para que
rápidamente puedan digamos evitar crisis
por ejemplo dicen la crisis yo veo
opioides opiáceos podría haberse evitado
porque norteamérica ha muerto a miles de
personas ha muerto por este consumo
digamos excesivo de medicamentos contra
el dolor podría haberse evitado esta
crisis si un estudio como el nuestro
hubiera existido porque hubiéramos dicho
a los médicos no les des este
medicamento porque los efectos
secundarios pueden ser gravísimas a
largo plazo
y dice pero ahora lo que queremos
investigar es por ejemplo ella trabaja
con adolescentes y con niños entonces
estamos están investigando la cuestión
de los medicamentos a base de marihuana
entonces bueno es un proceso interesante
graciela piñeiro y ella dirigió este
grupo internacional de investigación y
ya
lo que la semana próxima tenemos a dos
candidatos durante la semana de la
candidata liberal de la región de tu
zona y también la representante del
nuevo partido democrático
paulina ayala así que es exactamente
entonces ya nos vamos y nos vemos la
próxima semana del equipo
latinoamericano de radio que realmente
la flecha arrivederci
[Música]
ah